as a small aside
i think this is not the right time to
take the full journey
but i feel like you will guide me like
master uh
did and i'm the kung fu panda at
something they only have one
conversation
we're on our like we didn't well we're
we're we're jews and they weren't so we
talk too much
but the guy doesn't have to be with
words uh you don't think
poe is jewish it's debatable we'll have
to go back to the really like
yeah okay
is there um that you would guide me
through
some more intuition about
the source code the source code of our
universe
can you comment on where since we last
spoke
where your thinking has been has roamed
around geometric unity
around that work in physics in this
fight i'm trying to figure out
when to release it now i mean i've
released the video
and the video quite honestly i think it
has a very bizarre reaction
i think one of the things that i've
learned from the video because the video
is coming up on half a million
views on youtube alone to say nothing of
the
um the audio but
yeah it produced a very strange reaction
one of the things i don't think that i
properly understood is that most
physicists
don't talk in this geometric language
i thought that more of the physics world
probably had converted over into
manifolds bundles differential forms
connections curvature tensors etc
and i i saw a lot of the comments would
say things like i have a phd in
theoretical physics
and i'm not even familiar with all of
these concepts and
i think that was probably a distortion
coming from
living in cambridge massachusetts for
almost 20 years
so what's the solution to that well i
mean you translated into it
i can make this make as much sense as
anybody needs to my problem is
it's you know my calculation
is that as long as the boomers are still
in charge
the same people have these perverse
incentives on them
where they've invested in these programs
that didn't work so they're extremely
hostile and
kind of difficult to deal with the fact
that i'm not a physicist
has its own set of issues which is that
effectively it's like the hermit kingdom
they don't get any visitors
and they don't necessarily want somebody
you know rolling up and saying i know
how to do physics so i'm always very
clear i'm not a physicist
[Music]
that said if i wait too long i don't
know that theoretical physics is really
going to exist
after the boomers because everyone in
you i think you had wolfram on your
program i don't remember whether he said
this to you or brian keating
but he said something like everybody got
discouraged it was too hard
we can't do that guys we cannot do that
there's something about the
renormalization revolution that
innervated the physics community because
it taught them
just because you can see in this energy
regime doesn't mean you can extrapolate
somewhere else unless you understand how
you know coupling constants run and
what kind of uv fixed points exist blah
blah blah
somehow that discouraged people from
guessing from believing everything
became an effective theory
the beauty of the effective theory
wasn't taken to be
really the beauty of the universe just
the beauty of an energy level so i think
that renormalization
was one of the most important
revolutions that ever happened in
science
and also its interpretation by the
physics community was catastrophic
well the story i'm telling myself is
that in part i'm waiting for them to get
weaker
but on the other hand i don't know that
we have any time left and so
are you also thinking about ways of uh
you know you know the the podcast medium
is revolutionary for
public for discourse for what i mean i
don't even know the right words for it
are you thinking of revolutionary ideas
for re-energizing the physics community
so basically for communicating
everything
look i have a fantasy okay
my fantasy is that all of these things
are the same problem and it goes back to
this thing that i read about
in in feynman's uh books
about tartaglia they asked him this
question like what's the greatest thing
that ever happened in math
he says tartaglia's solution of the
cubic
it's just like the weirdest answer so
you're like
okay i'll bite why is it tartaglia's
solution to the cubic and he said
because it was the first time a modern
person had done something profound that
the ancients had failed to do
i was like oh i got it it's the thing
that opens up new psychology that says
maybe things are possible again
it's in your orchard you orchard
new farmers new people who can find
fruit that they can pick
and once you have one person do that
very often you get many like one of the
things that we're talking about with
eddie van halen
the reason that he created a revolution
and somebody like roy buchanan did not
is that you could follow eddie van gaal
you couldn't pioneer it
and maybe you couldn't play as well and
as cleanly and as fast and as
inventively
but you could follow once you understand
that there is a tapping
principle it was just the beginning of
something called percussive guitar
my belief is that once we start
innovating in the present
everything will come because everything
around us is screwed up
you